Shabani is a 14-year-old western lowland gorilla...
...who resides in Higashiyama Zoo and Botanical Gardens in Nagoya, Japan.
Though Shabani has been at the zoo since 2007,..
...it's only recently that ladies have noticed that he's super hot.
Maybe he had an awkward adolescent phase.
Now he's really come into himself.
He's still nice because he was like a homely, he was a little heavy as a young gorilla,...
...so he has that soft inside, but then that hard exterior.
You know that next time he gets interviewed he'd like,...
..."Oh, I was such a dork in high school."
"Nobody wanted to go out with me."
People have been sharing photos and videos of this gorilla like crazy.
But come on, people, control yourselves.
He's 14.